歡迎收看最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀 我是李兆華
今天台股的氣氛整個不一樣囉
上漲的加速高達1400多家
今天中場上漲了600多點
而且是越漲越高 越漲越高
今天的凌晨大家都在等
等灰達的財報跟法說
當然我們也知道
歷年已經連續十季
法說會後會下跌
但是這一次有些事情看起來不一樣
Valubin已经有部分交货装机测试
市场显然对整体AI股
又燃起了希望的火种
在这样的情况下
我们所谓的第二只脚
是不是已经打完了
正式要起功
站在一个预备线上呢
今天外资在现货市场也是买超的
而且空单是回补的
有很多的迹象都在暗示
好像行情快要正式启动
但是我们进场一定要注意安全
要了解产业的趋势
也要了解心态
所以来欢迎今天三位来宾了
第一位是K线之神
朱家宏 朱老师
朱老师上个礼拜来才在讲
第二只脚快要打好了
但今天的说法不同了
第二只脚应该是
打好了新的目标价
帮我们画出来了
今天台股有很多的公司
创下历史新高
最引人注目的
例如像大力光
整个光学是非常的热
所以朱老师说
只要该族群有人创下历史新高
有领头羊
那我们进场学什么呢
看高做低帮您挑
中低价同族群形态已经打好的
现在去买最佳安全
好第二位呢
是我们的产业趋势专家
王建文王博
王博一直都在帮CPU
光通讯送暖
从谷底送到联雅也要创新高了
好大力光也创历史新高的情况下
还有哪一些
其实这个族群反弹的程度
比较参差不齐
尤其美股前一阵子
其实有下跌
所以今天王博独家帮我们找
在光通讯CPU这个领域里面
他觉得位阶算低
而且法人大户在做聚集的
以及刚刚讲到的
辉达的新机即将要装机量产了
所谓的800伏这件事情
在今天的盘面上也受到瞩目
BBU相关的光宝科
300块大关上去了
那谁会接着紧接着往上走呢
等一下王博帮您选
好第三位
第一次来理财答案秀
是新面孔
但也是舊面孔喔
就是理財達人秀首代IP创辦人
現在在普惠頭顧擔任分析師的陳俞成
好 俞成來了
好 俞成來了喔
剛剛跟他話家長非常的久
但他今天要強調一件事情喔
今天晚上揮答的財報會不會不一樣
延續實際喔
每次看完財報不管講多好
都是往下殺
但是VR Ruby提早已經交貨給大家了
这件事情带动的叫做
PCB规格
全面拉好拉满
等一下余晨文告诉大家
PCB现在走向一个叫无步化
好 到底谁受惠 谁受害
台场的受惠名单
等一下一次告诉您
好 首先有请朱老师
你好
朱老师
这肯定句
第二脚打完
台股的新目标价
真的很振奋
不过今天很多唱新高的股票
都几千块
可能大家觉得追不上
但没有关系
今天帮我们挑的都是
中低价抵不起张股
那我记得上次有讲
我们回来有个最重要的支撑
就是月线不要跌破
其实真正关键的是昨天
不是今天
因为昨天如果不拉的话
这个月线就不保了
那你昨天打个电话给我
我就要让您跟明汉互换
对 昨天这一根最重要
因为它如果下去
你看我们盘中有下了
五六百点后来又拉了
拉到月线
对对
所以昨天这一根就透露出来说
这个月线是可以撑住的
它可以撑住
第二个呢
昨天这里各位看
回档一天两天三天四天五天
昨天是第五天
就在这个横盘
它没有上去也没有下来
那今天就来决定了
它为什么讲今天确认因为今天的收盘把这五天全部都过了是就說一根紅可以吃了五根K線的高跌所以今天這根K線就很漂亮了
因為它收在相對高跌
它沒有留什麼上限
那第二個量
今天佔上五日均量
這個很重要
你看我們從這個地方
一路量一路鎖
我們都上禮拜也講
我們沒有量就沒辦法
所以我們為量試問
只要你看到量能夠持續放大
它就會開始往上去挑戰
好 因為今天確認了
在底部來講
因為這是空頭
現在轉多頭
因為這已經過高
所以這邊是頭頭高
我們講了
一定要來一個第二隻腳
它就變多了
但第二隻腳有好有壞
那這個第二隻腳就很強
因為它在月線上
現在的第二隻腳
我們叫做N字底
所以用N字底來算目標價
可以到51,326
直接算给大家看了一下
对 这叫目标价
可能当然也要一段时间
或者遇到历史高点
还会在那边震荡
这个大家先做好心理准备
那整理好了以后
如果历史高点过
其实到51326也没有太远
是啊
只有3000点
前面是48000
对 只有两三千点
所以过那个历史高点
应该目标价也可以
也容易的就到了
我们现在的股票
有很多都是创高了
那只有一个就是台积电
还没有上历史高点
台积电在这边算升盘要角
对 那我们上礼拜也讲过
为什么台积电现在看起来比较弱
但是它并没有跌
它还在这个地方
那就是把空间让出来
那这时候如果像我们刚才的大盘
要去攻历史高点
这个台积电就会上来
它就会出来
所以台积电有台积电人
也就稍微的等一下了
它並沒有說走壞或什麼
因為我們上禮拜也講
台積電目前來說
它只要過了2445多頭就反轉
就完成了
那這個完成多頭
當然就會挑戰歷史高點
不過這邊的話
它也是代表揮打概念
所以今天全值有在指數上面
給予貢獻之外
還有創新高的刷一排
結果各位有沒有發現
創歷史高點的股票一摞框
所以大力光不要走
這裡有目標價
形態目標價
大家可能自己可以練習一下
大地觀我相信大家
一看就看出來形態了
對不對 這就是一個圓壺底
我不敢說 很簡單
這個是圓壺底
這個圓壺底可以到7035
其實大概還有700塊
大概700塊吧 710
因為它還是多頭
所以你既然已經抱那麼久了
那你就繼續做
那空手那就看這個空間
你要不要去做
因为空间大概也算有限
大概一层
大概还有一层的空间
好 那联谊光也是创历史高点
光学概念
今天好几档
但是联谊光的这个目标价
已经快到了
因为它的目标价是128.5
这在周线里面去看
周线是中期
周线是一个N字底
所以周线会到128.5
但是并不是说128.5
到了就没有了
不是這個意思
就是說它因為有個型態
它會往這個方向走
那走到了如果多頭不變
當然就繼續走
它還會繼續創新高
好 那關寶科
這個目標價也過了
這個陽城也過了
陽城這一陣子
也是一直漲一直漲
所以它的目標價也到了
好 那彩虹
它因為沒有型態
好 那創意也是創歷史高點
對 創意創歷史新高
6100 它的目標價是6900
接近7000啊
可以去用形態推估
大家都可以用形態去看
有的在日線 有的在週線
因為有的在日線上
你這樣看起來很亂
其實你回到週線就很清楚
它就有一個ABC突破
這個飄期的形態
全部都會出現
朱老師像光寶科
大家現在那麼注目它
過了那怎麼辦
過了就照多頭去做
回後買上漲
因為我們大盤才剛剛反轉
所以很多的股票在底部打底可是我們打底各位一定要去觀察這個條件要做好否則你太早進場可能會被耗在裡面
比如說這個季線還有壓力
月線還沒有做好
那你進去了可能
別的股票都漲
你的股票沒漲
但是你要抱住
如果你進去就要抱一抱
最重要我們剛剛有講
你空頭一定要打個底底高
一定要完成
那底底空頭在反彈的時候
這個地方就會形成壓力
所以這裡有一條壓力線
只要它回來底底高
那你就很簡單了
上面這個壓力 下面是支撐
這個中間怎麼走都不要管
因為各種走法
有的是預月線又回來
但是最後這個壓力要過
因為這個壓力一過
多頭就確認
一定要等到這個
但是有的很快
咚咚咚就過了
有的搞了一兩個月才過
但是不管它早晚過
我們都是以技術面去確認它
那如果你多頭確認
卻在季線下
那表示你這支股票只能做短線
會遇到壓力
對 因為季線有壓
所以你如果遇到季線回來
你這個地方要賣一趟
所以我這裡有寫請你停利出去一趟
出去一趟如果回來
再來回後買上漲 對不對
如果都在月線季線上
這你四線多排
你也可以做長線
這邊波段就可能拉出來
可能這個會有一波兩波
因為這個叫出聲段就開始了
它可能會有主聲段 末聲段
所以底部這樣子都反轉
在中間你再看這裡有沒有大量
如果在打底的時候都有大量
那都代表這支股票
有主力在這裡已經事先佈局了
它已經先買了
或者是那個800張 1000張的大戶
大家都可以去看
就可以找到资料
好 那我们来看一下
这个
刚刚已经讲说
有光绝股
大力光 对不对
郁金光 阳明光
对
就是有蛮多
今天光学股市的表现非常强势
但是有的创
有的还在底部打底
那我们可以看吧
领头羊都已经上去了
那这些同类的
是不是有好的股票的形态
或者底部
那我们就可以去介入了
好 我们来看一下
好 陽明光在今天也是今天
因為這個地方有個壓力嘛
對不對 那這個壓力呢
今天收盤就過了
那這一過這也是可以把它當作
一個圓弧底
只是這個圓弧底的右把柄打得比較久
就是它到壓力沒有過
如果這邊過就是一個標準的圓弧
對嘛 但沒有過
那這個就是在右邊打右把柄
那打右把柄今天過均線也做好了
20均已經碰到60均
這樣子的話它就有目標價了
因為圓弧就會到105.8
以這個目標價來講
再以這個底部的量來講
這裡有量
是有機會去過97.8
因為97.8大概就這一根量
大量
我們這邊很多量
好多天的量
所以再加上我們講大戶
也都在這裡佈局
所以這支股票是有機會
有機會去到目標價
但是大家要切進去
還是要按照我們節目
每次跟大家講的
不要追高 回後買上漲
回後買上漲
而且如果它真的破線了也要走
對
那這一支就是我們剛剛講
上了月線季線有壓
所以它回來
今天打了第二隻腳
這是第一隻腳
這是第二隻腳
可是它上月線的時候過了前高
所以它跟我們的大盤是一樣的
先過前高
然後出第二隻腳
所以它今天是多頭確認
但是因為季線還沒上
所以有可能明天碰到季線
這裡又出一個黑K
但是大家如果要鎖它
最好是讓它上了季線
上來也許兩天三天
下一次都回後買上來
因為它這邊這個量也不小
上引線超級長
要克服
還有一個就是
它要過季線
應該這邊還是會放量
它還會放量所以我們等它拉回來這邊連續過季線兩三天放大量 回來量縮然後再供至少它有一個空間80到100
這個空間真的過不去
你也不會賠錢
只是你大概就賺到這了
過去你的獲利就會比較高
還有另外非光學族群的
其實散落在各領域
都有這種底部形態完成的
這些就是符合我們剛才
教學的那個圖的
在底不打底的
有的是多頭完成的
有的上了月線還沒過季線
還有的也許過了季線
那這裡面大家就可以去看
其實這些股票
都是大家很熟悉的股票
因為在前面這個七月以前
都是很會張
你看這個藍牙是不是
很會張
很活潑
只是七月到八月就一直跌
可是現在它抵出來了
你看都漲停板了
我一直講
一個空頭股票
如果跌到不管跌到哪裡
你一出現漲停板
這個地方大概就不太容易再破
表示多方轉強
那我們不妨看看
有沒有這些好股票
好 CPU 的重達 KY
你看這是不是很標準的
先上了月線會到季線
那季線有壓
所以你這邊就會回來
回來的觀察就是月線不要跌破
那今天就確認了
對不對 今天是不是這個就過了
所以他多頭確認
好給王伯面子
我一直跟他讲
空头转多头
现在唯一的就是均线
这个月线还没有穿过季线
可是如果你下一次来看
月线就穿过
那这里就可以去挑战
是 这边也是大量高点
它都是空转多
多再往上去
那回来也一样
从高点就回到上次的低点
就回到上次的低点
所以这就是我们标准的一个底部股票
那这支股票在这里就完成多
跟這個一樣反彈 橫盤 突破
就完成多頭
那現在因為季線有壓
也許你沒有做 回來了
我剛剛有講嘛
你上季線再拉回來
那現在就拉回來了
所以今天這個叫做回後買上漲
那這個量就夠了
它中間在跌的時候
完全沒有量
那這個代表什麼意思
這個最大量一定是散戶買的
閃戶買了嘛
那就是閃戶還抱在手上
還抱在手上
那會不會形成上漲的壓力
沒有 現在就等解套
其實很快
這個已經沒有很遠了
它只要一完成多頭
它雖然有閃戶還抱著
但是因為有主力 大戶都進來了
那它容易去解套
如果閃戶稍微耐心一點
因為它已經轉多了
不許不要再去
那這支股票大家
也許不一定看得懂
但是我給大家解釋一下
這是空一定沒問題吧
南亞
這一定是空頭
是
對不對 投投地底底
不過它厲害是它在地線指
對 它在地線撐住
那你空頭要再轉強
一定要變多
是
這個就是底底高來了
今天是底底高
那換句話講
明天過了這個
它就變多了
是 變投投高
好 那現在多空要對視
这是空嘛 这是多嘛
那就看谁厉害了
那如果这个多把230过
它就会大涨一波
就会涨这样一段
涨一波
它就会涨一段
因为在技术分析有一个口诀
这叫空转多
又过了空高
过了空的高点
这边就会大涨
我存讲技术没有
因为基本面这些都有专家在讲
别担心 第三段
对 技术面如果把230过
那这日股票就另外一个空间
因为我们讲的那些几千块
都在创历史高点
这个才几百块
所以当然还有空间可以去期待
还有空间期待
好 朱老师感觉出了有一些考题
要后面两位来宾来接招
可是整个形态看起来
其实高高低低都有可以做的股票
所以形态已经完全是好转的状态
沒錯
非常謝謝莊老師